when i was a child
my brother would tell me a bedtime story
about the man who murdered our father
about all the things we would do to that
man
he never should have trusted cersei you
never should have either
death i've got many faces
i look forward to seeing this one how
long do we have
before the sun comes up tomorrow
[Music]
i wasn't a king but you were the fact
that john's
real parents were who john's real
parents were is not news to us at this
point but what we don't know
is the way that john is going to take
this
how's the explosion gonna look sam as a
brother of the night's watch and john
or more brothers than brandon john ever
really were he knows it's going to hurt
john and it's going to shatter his whole
worldview for all they know the army of
the dead could attack the next day
and someone has to tell john before that
he's being told something that he both
knows is true and
can't handle so he tries to throw
things in front of it to prevent him
from having to deal with
the truth of what he's being told the
thing he throws in front of it here is
the fact that it means his father was
lying to him
his whole life you've never been the
bastard
you are true heir to the iron throne the
truth that samwell tells john
is probably the most incendiary fact in
the entire
world of the show we chose to play the
whole thing
on john's face because as great a job as
john bradley is doing presenting this
information he's really just presenting
information we know already
daenerys is our queen you shouldn't be
that's treason it's the truth
hi everyone it's charlie we got our
brand new game of thrones season 8
episode 2
trailer to break down there's a whole
bunch of new scenes obviously they're
still getting ready for the big battle
so if you're brand new to the channel
i'm doing game of thrones videos all
season long be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing that hbo now
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video
obviously careful for spoilers from
episode 1 if you haven't seen it yet
but we see jaime facing the alliance
council in daenerys to answer
for one not only showing up without the
lannister army that he promised but also
answering for his past misdeeds they're
sort of taking him to task for all the
terrible things that he's done
because right now he's basically
surrounded with all the people who have
been his worst
enemies since season one of the tv show
so now he's sort of trying to make good
on his promises i'm trying to do a good
thing so he has to explain that to him
you see him panicking as the scene goes
on just looking all over the place
looking at bran still freaked out from
when he arrived that was one of my
favorite reunions during episode one so
he arrives and they have this mere
moment from season one episode one where
he pulls his helmet off and you know
shakes his golden locks but this time he
pulls his hood off and runs his hands
through his hair again
but he's got so many more city miles on
him look at how much older he looks from
the pilot episode
then bran just gives him that creepy
calm stare
as if he's piercing his soul with his
eyes usually when bran stares at someone
during an episode it implies that
something bad is about to happen
like when he stared at daenerys i
wondered what it was that he was peering
into the future because remember he has
green sight so he does have limited
visions of the future and he can see
their past pretty easily as well
he's a little bit better at seeing the
past than he is at seeing the future
because the future can change
but like we're all thinking about
visions daenerys's vision the house and
the undying
we'll see how much things can change and
how much of it's predetermined
but i love daenerys's speech there
apparently viserys told her all kinds of
stories about the king slayer the man
who murdered our father
even though the mad king deserved to die
and was one of the most terrible people
in history
it's a little bit weird that daenerys is
upset that he was killed i think she's
more upset about having to live in exile
and being away from her home her entire
life
not so much that she loved her father
like i think she understands what a
terrible person he was
but i think just in general this is
jamie having to answer for all of his
past
misdeeds now you look at sansa she's
just kind of giving me a cold stare i
don't think that she had any really bad
encounters with him in king's landing
while she was trapped by the lannisters
i think it's more by association because
she probably knows what was going on
between jamie and cersei at least by
this point even if she didn't know it at
the time
if there's any lannisters that she has a
grudge against though it would be cersei
she's the one that she's mostly focused
on because she used to idealize cersei
she wanted to be the queen but now she
knows the truth of things
remember back during season one too she
was so smitten with jamie because he was
quote-unquote prince
charming but then obviously the big
twist by the end of the episode is
that he's sleeping with his sister and
he tried to kill bran
nikolai koster waldo actually said
something funny in the behind the scenes
for the episode where he's like if bran
tells everyone what i did then i'm
absolutely screwed
you notice bran giving him the cold
stare in the room here obviously bran
doesn't hold a grudge anymore just
because he sort of left behind a lot of
that i think he remembers his human life
but like when jon snow said
you're a man now and he basically tells
him not quite like i'm not quite
human anymore john's kind of shaken by
it it's just a way to remind you that he
sort of left those things behind which
is why he stops them in that moment says
we don't have time for this
the army of the dead is coming they have
a dragon you see tyrion over on the side
here with a worried look on his face
please don't feed my brother to the
dragons then there's the scene with
daenerys and sansa dealing with the
aftermath of that and what they're gonna
do now that they know that cersei isn't
sending any help
when they sort of shade each other for
trusting things that cersei says i'm not
sure why daenerys is mad at sansa
because sansa's big thing during episode
one was taking tyrion to task for
believing cersei so it's not clear if
there's something that cersei said that
sansa believed maybe she's talking about
things that happened earlier on the show
during season 1 season 2.
everyone's in their new outfits except
for tyrion jorah and varys
sansa has her special new leather armor
on it's a huge upgrade and daenerys has
her new red fur
dress we get the aria voice over from
the original trailer death has many
faces i look forward to meeting this one
talking about the night king and the
white walkers holding up that
dragonglass dagger
you see gendry forging more dragonglass
weapons the stark soldiers the dothraki
bloodriders the knights of the veil the
unsullied all making their preparations
it seems like they're testing this
ballista or trebuchet in the daylight
just getting ready because it's before
the actual battle because the battle
itself doesn't seem like it starts till
nightfall just based on the previous
trailer footage we've seen like when the
white walkers horse walks up into frame
it's
fully night by that point you see that
samwell has already given sir jorah
heartsbane i wonder what that
conversation is going to be like
sorry about yesterday and telling you
about your parents sorry my queen
daenerys burned them alive
can i borrow that valyrian sword by the
way if you're not going to be using it
during this big battle
we haven't really had any moments
between the little bear and sir jory yet
because remember there's all that he
fled ned stark's justice because he was
slaving his people so the north
remembers the little bear is sort of
like team
mean girls this season ser jorah is on
my death predictions list
but if he were to survive it'd be
interesting to see if he just continues
trying to serve daenerys or if he would
ever
want to go home but because he's so
devoted to her i think that as long as
he's living and breathing he'll just
continue to stay by her side and serve
her in whatever way he can
there's a shot of daenerys entering the
crypts of winterfell to go talk to jon
snow obviously he's still
shook by the news of his true parentage
i do think that daenerys learns the
truth during this episode at some point
he probably tells her
it'll probably cause all kinds of
problems for their relationship and make
things within the alliance that much
more tense before the big battle
but then there's a shot of arya testing
out the dragonglass arrows i think it's
a nice callback to the pilot episode
when she was showing up bran and the
other stark children in the yard
just being a really amazing shot
jon snow talking to tormund before a
nightfall who's just arrived with the
rest of his band of wildlings and
probably the night's watch as well
telling them all about the night king's
abstract art installation the fact that
they're coming
there were a lot of people that were
curious about what exactly that message
means what the symbol means because it
keeps recurring the night king has been
making it since season one of the show
so i'll probably do a separate video
about that later this week
then jon snow this seems like ed in the
middle and samwell on top of the wall
because they were all members of the
night's watch and they stood atop
the wall back during season one so it's
a nice call back to them being brothers
of the night's watch they're literally
watching the night
move in as in the night king so just a
lot of visual metaphors and callbacks to
season one of the show just like we saw
during episode one
sir jorah riding into formation on his
horse with heart spain attached to his
hip
grey worm saying goodbye to missandei
grey worm is also on my death
predictions list
but the actor who plays him said that he
would have a very unsettling storyline
so i'm wondering if he's one of the
characters that they raise
as a white like one of the good
characters that we've been following
this whole time that then turns around
and becomes this undead zombie coming
for the other heroes
that would be another great horror
moment like the one that we got with
little lord umber at the end of episode
one
so everybody let me know in the comments
which other main characters you think
are going to come back as whites during
one of these big battles
but then there's a shot of daenerys with
a really sad and worried look on her
face
maybe this is her either being worried
about the big battle that's coming up or
maybe she's already found out about jon
snow being a secret targaryen
there's so many upsetting things that
she could learn that would cause her to
make this face
but then you see jon snow in the yard in
his new outfit preparing for battle
then tyrion at night before the battle
starts peeking his head over the walls
which is a nice mirror for his scenes
during black water back during season
two
too bad this time they don't have a crap
ton of wildfire to unleash on the night
king's army
the really interesting thing i think we
all need to pay attention to in this
episode is
tyrion's storyline as well because what
happened during blackwater he saved the
city with his wildfire plan but then
didn't get
any credit for it so because everybody
has been hating on him and he's been
making so many bad decisions
what might wind up happening is is that
he has a great idea for defending
winterfell
but because he looks like such a fool
cersei not bringing her reinforcements
and him just doubling down on that so
much
maybe they don't listen to him and
something terrible happens
and it just winds up leading him down
this darker path this season because
we're sort of seeing the downfall of
tyrion like he used to be super clever
he was amazing the first couple of
seasons super witty
the last couple of seasons he's just
been making one bad call after another
so this just seems like it's going to be
the next step in that descent so pay
special attention to what's going on
with tyrion during the episode but then
there's that scene of jon snow and
samwell talking about treason daenerys
jon snow's true parentage
it all gets tied up in the idea of
fixing the realm
after they're all done remember how
tyrion varus and davos were talking
about the solution
well the best thing to do would just be
to get the two of them married
the only thing that's complicating that
right now is that john is a secret
targaryen in getting over the fact that
she's really his aunt is he comfortable
with that how are they going to handle
that going forward
i think the main idea here is that they
love each other so eventually they'll
move past it and yes they will
eventually get married at some point
either during the season or in the
future of the show if they don't do some
giant jump forward in time
but short term is just meant to cause a
bunch of drama and chaos within the
alliance because remember they took him
to task for bending the knee we named
you king in the north
you're supposed to be our king so if the
north found out that he were the true
heir to the iron throne they would
probably be even more upset with
daenerys for trying to assert her claim
so it's all just meant to complicate
things as we head into this giant huge
battle
let me know in the comments what you
guys are most excited about for episode
two
what'll happen is is i will do a q a
video tomorrow so leave any questions in
the comments that you want me to include
in that and there'll be some more bonus
videos later this week congratulations
to the giveaway
winner from my last big video ryan brown
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your details
click here for my game of thrones season
8 episode 1 video
and click here for my game of thrones
season 8 death predictions
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight